well back here in germany the german
president frank walter steinmeier today
said that germany needs to take
responsibility for its colonial past he
made the comment at the opening of two
new exhibitions at berlin's humboldt
forum museum complex
the exhibits contain about 20 000
african and asian artifacts and the
origins of some of those objects
are controversial
expressive faces decorated with
thousands of colorful beads adorn the
king's throne from cameroon it's one of
the most spectacular exhibits and one
that shows how difficult it is to handle
objects from the colonial era it was a
gift from the sultan to the kaiser but
how freely given a gift to a colonial
master then there's the large boat from
luff island in what's now papua new
guinea 130 years old 15 meters long
that's without doubt but was it really
bought in 1903 in the colony of german
new guinea there's no evidence it was
many of the 3 000 objects shown here
have an equally unclear history but
clarifying their origins as president
steinmeier said in his opening address
is not the sole task of museums
essentially it's about our self-image
our responsibility before history we and
by that i mean europeans as a whole will
have to overcome established thought
patterns and encourage ourselves to
perceive and accept other perspectives
the humble forum museums are taking on
the task the history of the artifacts is
explained in booklets and online the
museums also want to showcase the great
artistic and cultural significance of
works from africa asia and oceana such
as the 1400 year old cave paintings from
kuka on the silk road which are on
display in a specially designed room
well the opening of the humboldt forum
comes as namibia debates whether or not
to accept a 1 billion euro offer from
germany to compensate for colonial era
atrocities germany is seeking to atone
for its genocide against the herrero and
name people in the first decade of the
last century yesterday 300 protesters
climbed the fences of parliament to
express their anger over the
compensation plan they say the proposal
is a sellout and does not effectively
address the atrocities of german
colonialism the parliamentary debate on
the agreement is expected to be voted on
in the coming days
germany's foreign minister haiku moss
says that germany stands by its offer of
compensation and he says he hopes
namibia will ratify the agreement
we negotiated for a very very long time
over many years and the results that
have been achieved have been achieved in
the spirit of finally arriving at a
result not a conclusion
in this really difficult chapter of
german history
because it's actually just the beginning
of a very very intensive collaboration
between germany and namibia i would like
it to be seen that way in namibia but
ultimately that's a decision that will
be made in namibia
so from possibly looted artifacts to the
horror of colonialism how much should
germany pay and will it ever be enough
for more on this we're joined tonight by
joshua qwesi akins joshua is a political
scientist and a human rights activist
joshua it's good to have you on the
program i mean where do we begin here
this is such a deeply sensitive issue
how can germany right the wrongs of its
colonial past and genocide
will money be enough
well certainly not i mean looking at
namibia it's very clear that three
things are required right there has to
be full recognition of the genocide
there has to be restitution of human
remains because thousands of human
remains skulls that were acquired in the
cosmic genocide are still um here in
germany
and of course there have to be
reparations and unfortunately we just
heard haiku master foreign minister
speak about the fact that he doesn't
want
you know this to be
the final stop but the beginning of a
process unfortunately the german offer
is really structured in such a way that
no further recompense will be possible
after this money is being paid and the
key issue the key criticism here is that
representatives of the groups of
survivors of the nama and the herrera
have not been present in these
negotiations so
the people that were wronged are not
part of the process of writing that
wrong and this clearly shows that
yeah i would say a colonial
continuity can be seen in the way that
the german government refuses to
directly engage with
those whose forebears whose ancestors
have been wronged have been murdered and
have been driven off their ancestral
land in namibia well joshua do we know
why representatives of the herrera and
the nama people have not been included
in in these negotiations i mean if one
would think that they would be the first
people to be invited
that's exactly the issue here um you see
i mean the african continent was divided
right here in berlin right and now the
german government says well
given those borders we can only
negotiate with the namibian government
which of course is a very convenient for
the german government since the libyan
government has very few herrera nama
representatives among them but of course
if you look into german history we
noticed that after the second world war
germany was able to negotiate not just
with the state of israel but with a
plethora of jewish diaspora groups which
was key
in achieving
you know a recompense for
the holocaust and so there's a clear
historical precedent and that's why
people in namibia say it must be
possible for germany to speak with us
directly too
there is also the subject of artifacts
that are believed to have been given to
germany that that's being debated how
easy is it to prove that art and other
valuables were not looted
well this is of course um a tricky issue
however if we look more closely in you
know
the previous video it was clearly stated
that we're talking about ten thousands
of objects the key issue here is not
whether a few of them might have been
gifted or not the key issue is that it's
on record that ten thousands have
directly been looted
there's documentation of that and there
are ten thousands of others where the
circumstances are not clear and so one
of the key criticisms lobbied against
the humboldt forum is that here we have
the biggest cultural project in europe
um 600
million euro were spent on erecting
this museum but
scant resources have been made available
to actually research into the provenians
of the objects that are going to go on
display there and that's a clear
discrepancy and that is why communities
literally from around the world are
saying you cannot put our heritage on
display you must put money into
researching
how this even got to berlin
joshuasi akins we appreciate your time
and your analysis valuable insights
tonight thank you
thank you